la liberté de ne même pas regardé le
peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain tout de suite les titres de
ce mardi 11 février 2001 l'heure des
retrouvailles et des explications
emmanuel macron reçoit en ce moment à
l'elysée à les députés de la majorité le
chef de l'état entend apaiser et
resserrer les rangs après l'épisode du
congé pour deuil d'un enfant
une séquence qui a laissé un goût très
amer dans les rangs de la république en
marche après le tollé suscité par le
refus d'allonger ce congé à 12 jours les
députés proposent maintenant de porter
le congé à trois semaines pour les
actifs à l'onu un baroud abbas rejette
le plan israélo américain pour le proche
orient devant le conseil de sécurité le
chef de l'autorité palestinienne a
plaidé en faveur d'une paix juste
il s'est dit prêt à négocier avec israël
sous l'égide du kart est pour le
moyen-orient
[Musique]
toujours aux etats-unis deuxième
séquence des primaires démocrates après
il y aura là y aura place au new
hampshire un scrutin crucial pour les
deux grands favoris
pitbull dj jay bernie sanders itéra cole
en tête des sondages dans cet état du
nord-est du pays et les piques entre
candidats se multiplient dans la
campagne des candidats qui n'ont qu'un
seul point commun est la volonté de
battre donald trump est la turquie la
firme plus de 150 soldats syriens ont
été neutralisés hier ankara aurait
répondu à l'offensive syrienne a est
libre dans laquelle cinq militaires
turcs auraient péri elle les chiffres
n'ont pas été confirmés par damas pour
le moment l armée turque se serait
également attaqué à des blindés du camp
syrien récupère doan a affirmé que le
pouvoir syrien peyrat est très cher
toute nouvelle attaque
[Musique]
au liban le parlement accorde sa
confiance au nouveau gouvernement et ce
malgré la mobilisation de centaines de
manifestants dès l'aube pour empêcher
les députés d'accéder au parlement dans
le centre ville de beyrouth les
manifestants dispersés par les forces de
l'ordre accusé les politiciens de
corruption généralisée et de mauvaise
gestion
[Musique]
opération un des ménages donc pour le
président emmanuel macron il reçoit en
ce moment même les députés de la
majorité
unité et cohésion sont les mots d'ordre
affiché pour cette soirée avec un
échange direct selon l'elysée après
plusieurs couacs notamment celui du
congé pour deuil d'enfant à mais aussi
sur fond des réformes des retraites
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
devant l'elysée notre reporter katia
technique avec katia bonsoir alors quel
est le contexte de cette réunion alors
déjà je voudrais préciser que nous avons
pu voir les députés entrer un ballet de
voitures est arrivé près de l'elysée ils
vont être reçus
le contexte est bien on parle de
calinothérapie dans la presse pourquoi
parce que les tensions sont vives depuis
quelques semaines on se souvient de ce
fameux vote contre l'allongement du
congé en cas de deuil d'un enfant
les parlementaires n'avait fait que
répondre aux conseils du aux consignes
du parti
et ensuite emmanuel macron les avait
exhortés à davantage d'humanité bien sûr
ces propos ont été très mal perçu
certains députés se sont sentis trahis
donc c'est principalement ce couac qu'il
faudra résoudre alors il s'agit donc
pour le président de recréer du lien
d'apaiser les tensions c'est cela oui en
effet surtout que si on tient compte du
contexte qui est très difficile par
ailleurs en effet les députés doivent
maintenir le cap de la réforme des
retraites coûte que coûte même si elle
est parfois très content contesté au
sein de leur circonscription il faut
ajouter à cela la bataille des
municipales particulièrement féroce avec
une opposition très forte et ce dans un
contexte social assez calamiteux
puisqu'il ya beaucoup de blocages de
manifestations les gilet jaune
d'ailleurs de nombreux députés ont vu
leurs permanences vandalisé et puis au
sein de l'assemblée nationale il y a
aussi des couacs 1 puisque certains
parlementaires reproche à d'autres
d'être un peu trop aux ordres du
président ou alors d'être trop
déconnectés du terrain
parlons aussi
des députés de gauche qui peuvent être
un peu choqué par à la direction prise
par le gouvernement
donc ça fait déjà beaucoup de petites
tensions ajoutons à cela le fait que les
députés reprocherait à emmanuel macron
d'être trop distant en effet c'est
seulement la troisième fois qu'il reçoit
les députés depuis depuis son mandat on
sait que mme naima qu'on n'aime pas les
dissensions
il sera peut-être il y aura peut-être un
possible rappel à l'ordre de sa part on
sait qu'une dizaine de députés déjà ont
quitté le groupe
la république en marche à l'assemblée
depuis le début du mandat alors est ce
que ce sera une calinothérapie ou un
conseil de discipline en tout cas dans
ce contexte pas sûr que les députés
après si un mariage du chaud et du froid
merci beaucoup catia pour toutes ces
précisions katia technique en direct de
l elysée et pour en parler nous sommes
avec et ghislaine pierrât docteur en
communication politique ghislaine tira
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
alors à quoi assiste-t-on ce soir une
calinothérapie comme on a pu l'entendre
ou bien davantage un conseil de
discipline finalement alors d'abord le
terme calinothérapie est un terme
imbéciles en politique il faut jamais
perdre le sens que tous les politiques
sont là pour porter l'histoire
collective
l'histoire de la france donc on n'est
pas chez les bisounours
il s'agira souvenez-vous en septembre en
septembre il y avait eu quelques paroles
douces au départ et puis après il y
avait eu une remise à l'ordre des
troupes parlementaires
là c'est pas du tout la même chose parce
que on a des crises épisodique qui
révèle un vrai malaise et macron a bien
vu que l'histoire de l'excellent
parlementaire guy bricout avec le deuil
par le parental il ya eu bon le propos
comme quoi macron disait aux
parlementaires vous manqué d'humanité ce
qui n'était pas le cas
l'histoire des retraites donc on a quand
même quelques contentieux là ce soir ça
va être un dialogue ça va être des
questions-réponses ça va être une soirée
un peu particulière
mais il s'agit pas de calinothérapie
bien évidemment il va y avoir un vrai
dialogue selon vous parce que on
souvient certains craignent justement
que de voir le chef de l'état a
finalement parlé peut écouter comme
certains l'avaient constaté d'ailleurs
lors des grands débats
il va changer cette position cette
posture est arrivé c'est à espérer parce
que les grands débats c'était vraiment
le le discours à l'infini ban qui était
trop long qui était intelligent qui
était riche mais il n'y avait pas cet
échange là a priori d'après les
informations de différents
parlementaires
ça va être davantage question réponse ça
va être davantage de dialogue et une une
explication
donc en fait je crois qu'il doit se
réconcilier avec les parlementaires
une explication vous lisiez qui
n'auraient pas pu se faire finalement
loin des caméras on le voit cette
réunion est largement médiatisée il ya
une volonté de l'elysée de médiatiser
cette rencontre ce rendez vous oui là là
on peut discuter effectivement sur la
médiatisation de cette soirée mais bon
c'est inévitable donc autant embrayé le
pas que de que d'empêcher les médias de
parler on parle de démocratie on parle
de vie parlementaire on parle de
l'elysée du président de la république
est tout à fait normal que les médias
bon relate l'événement est bien
évidemment à la sortie y aura des
micro-trottoirs surtout les
parlementaires sur ce qu'ils auront
pensé de cette soirée
alors justement des parlementaires vous
le vous le disiez dans un certain
malaise il ya eu tous ces couacs mais au
fond le malaise est il plus profond
qu'est ce qu'il révèle oui vous avez
raison de relever cet aspect le malaise
il est
il est beaucoup plus profond parce que
l'assemblée nationale au fait
macron à un petit déficit
il est brillant il est intelligent mais
il n'a pas c'est le seul président
rendez vous compte de la 5ème république
qui n'a pas d'expérience de député alors
il lui manque un peu cette culture
parlementaire et concrètement ils
doivent changer des choses
la plateforme en a jusqu'à contrairement
à à un mitterrand contrairement à
sarkozy contrairement à hollande
il n'a jamais été députée donc il faut
qu'ils les poussettes culture
parlementaire
il faut qu'ils l'aiment l'assemblée
nationale et aimer l'assemblée nationale
pour moi c'est déjà un gros gros pavé
que vous appeliez malaise profond de
l'écu âgées l'écu âgées c'est un petit
terminologie baroque questions au
gouvernement exactement questions au
gouvernement
et donc ces questions avant c'était le
mardi et le mercredi
ça faisait vivre l'institution c'est
c'était une heure de 15 heures à 16
heures et après les parlementaires aller
vers les médias voyaient les ministres
et la maison vivait cette assemblée
nationale c c'est un formidable exemple
de démocratie dans le monde entier et
bien évidemment que les quais l'écu
âgées question gouvernements doivent est
de nouveau le mardi et le mercredi tous
les partis plus qu'aujourd'hui et
nilesat basé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est le mardi de 15 heures
à 17 heures c'est insupportable pour
tout le monde et tout le monde dit mais
c'est pas possible
bon c'est ces trolls c'est trop c'est
trop condensé on ne fait pas un bon
boulot il faut revenir à la formule
d'avant moins de dialogues plus de
dialogue c'est ça à l'assemblée
nationale finalement aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale les gens
samson malheureux ils ont ils ont besoin
de de proximité et puis il ya aussi les
municipales les municipales il ya des
parlementaires qui n'ont pas démérité et
tout d'un coup paf on leur impose
quelqu'un pour briguer une mairie qu'il
voulait briguer donc il ya beaucoup de
déçus il ya beaucoup de gens au delà du
dialogue comme vous le disiez au delà du
dialogue
il ya aussi bondée des gens qui
comprennent pas pourquoi
n'ayant pas démérité bon tout d'un coup
ils ne peuvent pas briguer une mairie
comme il l'aurait souhaité tout c'est
quoi que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est quoi c'est ça relève d'un manque
d'expérience chez les députés de la
république en marche vous êtes encore
autre chose
non moi je trouve ça bien sûr qu'au
départ ils sont arrivés c'était les
bleus qui débarquait mais beaucoup ont
appris beaucoup sont très méritants
passionnés bon il ya quelques
hurluberlus que tout le monde a déjà
repéré sans les citer mais mais sinon
bon il faut il faut retravailler et ils
sont très assidus ils sont très
appliqués
donc bon après tout on est loin quand
même de la période initiale où il y
avait d une tous les quatre matins de
députés qui avaient fait des choses un
petit peu extravagante la non les gens
sont appliquées bosse vraiment il faut
revaloriser le politique en france il
faut revaloriser le travail
parlementaire et macron seraient bien
inspirés des mets l'assemblée nationale
de mieux faire le nia souvenez vous au
lendemain hollande a reçu les
parlementaires qu'une fois mais sarkozy
recevait les parlementaires sans arrêt
maquereau a reçu seulement trois ou
quatre fois donc c'est pas beaucoup
il reçoit par commission régulièrement
mais c'est pas suffisant
la politique c'est extrêmement affectif
donc il faut la faire vivre ce soir
resserrer le lien avec ces
parlementaires à pouvoir le réaliser
emmanuel macron selon vous bah les
parlementaires sont
d'après ce que j'ai entendu assez
content d'aller à l'elysée
là on en a pas on n'a pas le plan de
coupes turquie kia qui arrive à l'elysée
mais bon je pense que d'après ce que
j'ai compris il ya beaucoup de
parlementaires donc y en a pas 15 qui
vont y aller
bon sur la majorité c'est-à-dire il ya
trois cent douze parlementaires il y en
a 14 de parts en est là sur les 312 ça
sera très intéressant de voir justement
le nombre des parlementaires qui s'est
rendu à l'invitation
vous parliez effectivement de ses 300
députés qui ont été invités il y en a
plus d'une dizaine qui sont partis
depuis l'élection du président macron
encore qu'est ce que ça veut dire
finalement ben ça ça veut dire que les
liens sont sont trop distendu il faut
impérativement que macron renou face de
la proximité
je fasse jouer la confiance est là à la
veille des municipales qui a priori vont
être assez douloureuse pour en marche
il est très important qui rebouge ses
troupes killer qui leur donne le champ
ce qui est un président ça donne des
perspectives
il doit expliquer où on va sur la
réforme des retraites
peut-être que ça serait bien qu'elle
soit incarnée aussi parlent par le
président les les là on va avoir un
débat à partir du 17
bon ça va être assez à s'est enflammé à
l'assemblée nationale et ça va être
assez assez compliqué à c'est assez
douloureux aussi bien que l'art la
réforme des retraites
c'est compliqué au niveau du financement
et vous avez vu que le conseil d'état a
dit votre qu'il est mal ficelé comment
le financent donc ça déstabilise quand
même les députés
en tout cas ce que cette cette soirée de
ce soir cette rencontre de ce soir peut
finalement être le signe d'un d'un
second souffle pour le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro cette soirée ce soir
j'ai bien compris votre propre et est ce
que ça peut être le départ d'un nouveau
souffle pour emmanuel van ryb le bar au
oui faudrait élections qui amènerait aa
doute à des décisions là la réforme des
retraites
elle est fondamentale il faut pas que ça
parte dans un cul-de-sac
bon on voit que la france a soumise à
multiplier les amendements et veut
absolument qu'on arrête
franchement c'est pas possible tout le
monde a compris en france que l'on vit
tous plus vieux et que bon set entre la
réforme à 60 ans et les 35 heures y'a de
quoi faire donc je crois que tout le
monde doit peut comprendre
encore faut-il faire une pédagogie
intelligente que étant donné que l'âge
des individus va en progression il faut
engager une réforme
par contre bon il ya peut-être des
points qu'ils soient améliorées
il doit absolument réussir cette réforme
des retraites alors c'est pas seulement
la soirée de ce soir qui va donner un
second souffle
c'est plus cette réforme des retraites
qu'il doit absolument réussir ils
doivent se mettre les moyens et à
attention il ya des gens qui les
interpellent mais les parlementaires
ils sont là pour contrôler l'action du
gouvernement ils sont dans leur rôle
donc il faut pas dire ya les bons il ya
les gentils ya les méchants c'est pas ça
ils sont dans leur rôle
donc cette réforme elle doit voir le
jour parce qu'elle est nécessaire et on
doit l'améliorer donc il faut être plus
dans l'état d'esprit où emmanuel macron
et ses troupes doivent améliorer cette
réforme doit coûte que coûte voir le
jour et après bon effectivement s'il
passe le cap parce que n'oublions pas
que les municipales ça va être quand
même un petit gars d'un de conques
donc du coup après il y aura un bonbon
un second souffle vous avez raison de
dire que quand on est à kairos politique
merci beaucoup ghislaine pira d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en communication
politique
ce soir les avocats se sont réunis en
assemblée générale extraordinaire cela
fait six semaines qu'ils sont mobilisés
justement contre la réforme des
retraites
on retrouve sur place à paris notre
reporter bonne à un mode et l'or
mona bonsoir alors que peut-on attendre
de cette assemblée générale ce soir
bonsoir lille vous l'entendez la
mobilisation des avocats ne faiblit pas
vous en ferez peut-être derrière moi des
avocats qui veulent continuer à la
mobilisation et la poursuite de la grève
ils sont plusieurs centaines à s'être
rassemblés ici pour cette assemblée
générale qui a débuté à 19h et qui
finirait autour de 22h à 23h je suis
actuellement avec caroline mécary
avocate au barreau de paris bonsoir à
vous merci d'être avec nous alors est ce
que la décision est définitive
vous poursuivrez la grève a très
clairement l'assemblée générale du
barreau de paris s'oriente vers une
poursuite de la grève et d'une grève
dure avec véritablement des
mobilisations devant les juridictions
correctionnelles grève du zèle avec la
présence des représentants du conseil de
l'ordre dans toutes les audiences
et là quand vous entendez les confrères
s'exprimer parce qu'il y en a qui
viennent prendre la parole c'est parce
qu'ils demandent à ce que l'ordre
interviennent dans chaque audience et
nous soutiennent face aux magistrats qui
parfois ne sont pas d'accord avec nos
demandes de renvoi
il ya des voix dissonantes pas tout le
monde est d'accord mais la plupart de
son nom il n'y a pas de voix dissonantes
en réalité on est tous pour la poursuite
de la grève on a même entendu un
représentant du barreau d'affaires venir
nous dire qu'il était solidaire et qu'il
participerait à la caisse de grève qui
va être mise en place pour aider les
confrères qui justement peuvent souffrir
de la grève
à paris on discutait tout à l'heure ce
mouvement là il est historique à ce
mouvement est totalement historique
c'est la première fois en 30 ans de bach
en tout cas que je vois une telle unité
de la profession il faut rappeler que le
conseil national des barreaux qui
représente les 70000 avocats de france a
appelé à la poursuite de la grève parce
que ce gouvernement n'écoute pas
n'entend pas et nous continuerons la
grève jusqu'à ce qu'il entende nos
revendications légitimes
les 164 barreaux de france sont en grève
et il faut une grève dure que vous avez
pu voir de différentes manières nicole
belloubet a regretté cette grève et elle
demande la fin de la grève aux avocats
qu'en pensez vous écoutez madame
belloubet les fonctionnaires agents
publics
elle est dans l'exécutif elle n'a pas
d'ordre à donner aux avocats qui sont
par définition une profession libérale
et indépendante nous ne prenons pas nos
ordres de madame belloubet vous allez
continuer cette mobilisation et skol
vous trouvez que le gouvernement est
allé [ __ ] finalement non le
gouvernement n'est pas à l'écouté c'est
parce qu'il n'est pas aller coûte que
nous amplifions notre mouvement de grève
s'ils étaient à l'écouté si nous
obtenions un tant soit peu le fait que
l'on créé à tiennent compte de notre
spécificité est bien évidemment que nous
arrêterions la grève mais comme il
n'entend pas eh bien nous continuons et
nous allons amplifier c'est à dire que
nous allons mettre en place des actions
judiciaires contre l'état
on va taper au portefeuille de l'état
comme vient de le dire là une jeune
femme qui est en train de prendre le
micro
c'est à dire que nous allons mettre en
jeu la responsabilité de l'état et nous
ferons toutes les procédures qu'il est
possible de faire par exemple
au palier du budget du de la justice ou
faisait-il été misérable en fait
aujourd'hui la justice et d'ailleurs
depuis plusieurs plusieurs décennies
dans fait depuis que le nicolas sarkozy
a été président de la république il a
mis en place des politiques publiques de
réduction de la dépense publique et ça
fait qd est évidemment l'institution
judiciaire
donc nous n'avons pas ces deux
magistrats nous n'avons pas cette
greffiers et les avocats comme les
greffiers les magistrats ne font que
colmater les trous
le budget de la justice est 62 62 euros
par habitant alors que si on prend
l'exemple de l'allemagne ces 144 euros
par an par habitant
donc là la justice en france est en voie
de clochardisation
c'est des mots assez forts que vous
employez on en discute et tout à l'heure
on s'attendait pas à ce que les avocats
aussi aillent dans la rue est ce que
c'est le c'est un des histoires et un
malaise accumulées depuis des années
finalement en fait cette réforme des
retraites pour les avocats c'est la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
mais s'il faut bien comprendre que cette
réforme des retraites pour les avocats
c'est la mort programmée d'un tiers de
la profession je rappelle que sur les 70
milles avocats qui exerce en france la
moitié 35 mille d'entre eux gagnent
moins de quarante mille euros par an et
c'est cela qui vont être durement
impactée par le doublement des
cotisations retraites c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes là rudy
solidaire dans la rue et dans les
assemblées générales des barreaux
finalement on parle pas c'est la
précarité des avocats je ne sais pas si
on ne parle pas assez de la précarité
des avocats mais ce que je sais c'est
que le projet de réforme des retraites
va aggraver la précarité des avocats
pour ceux qui sont dans une situation
précaire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous battons pieds et
poings et surtout avec larmes notre arme
de prédilection qui est à la fois la
parole et le droit justement sont ceux
qui ne connaissaient pas les pénibilités
ou léger problème puisqu'on pouvait
endurer
les avocates et le contexte actuel le
contexte actuel c'est que globalement un
avocat travaillant entre 60 à 70 heures
par semaine qu'il ne peut être rémunéré
à moins de 3000 euros par mois tout
simplement et qu' il a il doit une
profession libérale
s'il n'a pas de travail il n'a pas de
chômage s'il est malade il n'a pas
d'indemnités de la sécurité sociale s'il
veut se payer des vacances il n'y a pas
de congés payés
il doit provisionner l'argent de ses
vacances et payer les différentes
charges qui pèsent sur lui donc c'est
une mécanique est exigeant et difficile
nous avons une caisse de retraite
autonome bénéficiaires et solidaire
puisque nous reversons chaque année plus
de 100 millions d'euros aux autres
caisses de retraite qui elles sont
déficitaires
c'est de voir plusieurs centaines
d'avocats qui sont mobilisés dans avec
un seul et même objectif qu'est ce que
ça vous procure écoutez on a on est fier
de voir que le barreau de paris se
mobilisent et va faire comme tous les
autres barreaux de france il va de
comment dire il va continuer la grève
dur avec arrêt des désignations comme
vous venez de l'entendre
donc pour la défense d'urgence très
simplement merci beaucoup
caroline mécary sur toutes ces
précisions merci infiniment d'avoir été
avec nous
vous l'avez entendu olivier des avocats
qui vont continuer à se mobiliser plus
que la grèce va être reconduite et le
barreau paris n'est pas le seul il ya eu
le barreau de caen le barreau de nantes
également qui ont voté presque à lui
seul
idée pour poursuivre cette grève merci
mona amoud et l'or alors on le disait la
contestation des avocats contre la
réforme des retraites perturbent le
fonctionnement de la justice française
depuis le 6 janvier
le traitement des dossiers par les
tribunaux est paralysé retour en
chiffres sur les conséquences de cette
grève
[Musique]
et
edu
les
[Musique]
et
et dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur le plan de paix
américain au proche-orient mahmoud abbas
a exprimé son rejet de ce fameux deal du
siècle cet après midi à l'onu puis nous
resterons aux états unis avec une
nouvelle séquence des primaires
démocrates dans le new hampshire rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
il faut bien comprendre que les champs
de schiste pétroliers américains donc
quelques temps vont s'arrêter de
produire si vous voulez toutes les
données pétrolières sont confidentielles
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme
avec le pétrole de schiste les
américains soient énergétiquement
indépendant banon ils sont en train de
frôler l'indépendance mais pour le pour
le gaz il y semant mais pas au pétrole
non c'est puis là le puits de gist sont
des puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle
si le pétrole de schiste des cent cette
année suffisamment pour que ça soit d'un
notable à moins de vendre le tram ne
sera pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la planète terre dans un futur proche
les mêmes qasmi si un débris spatial
audard f quoi qu on touche un satellite
d'un pays mange cela pourrait engendrer
un conflit autour de la terre l'espace
est polluée
il dérive en orbite d'innombrables
débris des millions de fragments de
tailles variées incontrôlable il est
extrêmement difficile de les suivre tous
orne les accidents vont se multiplier
les vols habités risque de devenir trop
dangereux et les communications par
satellite vont se détériorer les
systèmes de navigation gps pourrait
devenir de moins en moins fiables
internet auquel nous sommes tous
tellement habitués pourrait
dysfonctionné et perdre en vitesse
le gadget préféré le confort de la haute
technologie
tout cela pourrait devenir totalement
inutilisable
il faudrait que les nations puissent se
regrouper notamment une troisième force
et c'est troisième force et l'europe
mais l'europe est incapable de faire ça
il y à une remise en cause de la
relation très privilégiée entre l'europe
et les étages et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous devrions développer un dialogue
france allemagne russie chic tout çà çà
çà çà çà çà paraît pas avancer dans le
bon sens quand même le risque pour nous
c'est de sortir de l'histoire
moi je suis convaincu que l'avenir des
relations internationales pour les 15
ans qui viennent c'est la relation entre
les etats-unis et la chine ou hors pair
si nous ne sommes pas capables d'être le
troisième pôle à ce moment là on aura
des fragilités et on sortira l'histoire
[Musique]
ils sont venus dans notre village deux
fois ils ont insisté pour que je vienne
avec eux ils ont dit qu'on avait trop
d'enfants
on m'a fait une piqûre je ne me souviens
plus de rien elles m'ont tenu les bras
bien comme ça l'autre comme ça
voulez-vous reproduire comme des lapins
comme des cochons d'inde verra à partir
d'aujourd'hui vous serez reconnaissante
envers seniors fugee mauvais parce que
vous n'aurez plus d'enfants une légende
effrayante a été créée autour de cela
dans le but d'entacher le gouvernement
de monsieur fujimori et ce cas ci il y a
eu très peu de quarts fort ses
obligations je demandais dieu s'il te
plaît prends moi d'ici pourquoi j'ai
tellement mal partout dans mon corps
pourquoi j'ai mal au ventre dans mes
visions je vois clairement des enfants
debout et assis qui pleure il demande de
l'aide
leur âme veulent sortir
ce sont les documents du ministère de la
santé qui évoque les campagnes de
stérilisation forcée il y avait des
quotas qu'il fallait respecter
tu n'as pas pu stérilisés
[Musique]
on dirait que ce navire est très simple
mais c'est pas du tout le cas
en réalité le vrai maître c'est l'ours
blanc est en 2d le brise glace
nous avons entrepris une mission unique
peut être la première de ce type dans
l'histoire de la marine russe
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20h30
heure française
son discours était très attendu depuis
la présentation du plan de paix
américain au proche orient le 28 janvier
dernier le président de l'autorité
palestinienne s'est exprimée tout à
l'heure devant le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu mahmoud abbas a rejeté cette
initiative pour lui elle remet en cause
les droits légitimes des palestiniens
il a réaffirmé que les etats-unis ne
pouvaient plus être le seul médiateur
pour une paix au proche orient
il a dénoncé la vision américaine d'un
état palestinien gruyère voilà le résumé
du projet qui nous a été présenté voilà
ce que l'on nous prévoit comme état
c'est un fromage suisse qui parmi vous
accepterait de telle ou telle situation
un tel état ce projet
mesdames et messieurs comprend la
consécration de l'occupation de la
négociation par des forces militaires
ainsi qu'un durcissement du régime
d'apartheid et avant même ce discours de
nouveaux rassemblements contre le plan
de paix américain se sont tenues à
ramallah en cisjordanie chez des
milliers de manifestants ont défilé en
brandissant des portraits et des
drapeaux pour apporter leur soutien à
leurs représentants et faute d'appui
international suffisant est les
palestiniens ont renoncé à la dernière
minute a demandé le vote d'une
résolution à l'onu
depuis l'annnonce par donald trump de
son plan de paix la situation entre
palestiniens et israéliens s'est
détériorée retour en images sur les
événements de ces derniers jours
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes en duplex
depuis londres avec catherine jacques
damas spécialiste du moyen-orient c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
catherine chaque balle bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
mahmoud abbas a donc exprimé son rejet
du plan américain cet après midi mais
qu'est ce que vous retenez tout
particulièrement de ses propos à part le
fait qu'il a effectivement rejeté ce
plan on peut tout ce que cela
représentait il a également déclaré
qu'il était prêt à revenir à la table de
négociations si l'onu agirait en tant
que médiatrice et je pense que cela est
clé dans son discours il ne souhaite pas
que les états unis aient le monopole de
la médiation il veut vraiment que la
communauté internationale intervienne et
renforce son action
est-ce que cela va s'incarner dans les
faits c'est une autre question
l'onu n'a pas un très bon passif dans ce
domaine s'agissant d'aller à l'encontre
de la volonté d'israël et de toute façon
toute résolution trop passionnelles sera
soumise un veto des états unis donc la
situation est très compliquée mais si je
peux rajouter cela le problème c'est la
légitimité car mood abbas son peuple
rejette également l'accord mais je ne
sais pas s'il est vraiment la meilleure
personne pour négocier un accord à
l'avenir et au niveau palestinien c'est
ça le problème principal
est ce que les personnes au pouvoir
représente vraiment le peuple qui sont
censés représenter
alors faute d'appui international
suffisant les palestiniens ont renoncé à
la dernière minute ça a demandé le vote
d'une résolution à l'onu
j'arrête de que je leur l'artisan du
plan de paix de donald trump a parlé de
la communauté internationale comme d'un
front présentant des fissures en cascade
est ce que c'est le cas selon vous oui
effectivement certains pays vont contre
l'israël parfois et ils payent le lourd
tribut pour cela
donc il n'a pas vraiment de consensus là
le sujet le conflit israélo palestinien
est très complexe et très chargé
émotionnellement aller à l'encontre
d'israël ou utilisé l'adjectif d'appart
eid le montre bien dire que israël mène
une politique d'apartheid contre la
palestine
cette déclaration forte et il est
difficile d'être complètement d'accord
avec cela pour le moment la communauté
internationale a eu du mal à de fuir à
se référer au toit internationale cela
est encore jamais c'était le cas
vis-à-vis d'israël
à chaque fois on donne le bénéfice du
doute aux israéliens alors qu'il
faudrait vraiment parfois réagir plus
fortement
donc il n'ya pas de sens de la justice
il n'ya pas d'intégrer t il est très
difficile de d'adopter une posture
sévère ou d'être un véritable médiateur
en l'occurrence donc c'est l'un des gros
problèmes dans cette situation israël et
la palestine devrait être considéré de
manière égale pour qu'il y ait de
véritables négociations mais ce n'est
pas le cas alors depuis l'annoncé par
donald trump de son plan de père on l'a
vu la situation entre palestiniens et
elien s'est détériorée après le discours
d'aujourd'hui de mahmoud abbas
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à de
nouvelles conséquences dans la relation
entre israël et la palestine selon vous
peut-être pour moi ce qui se passe c'est
que une tabasse a été manipulé par un
arrêt que je meurs il va se servir de
cette violence de ces protestations
afin de dire que les palestiniens ont
refusé cette proposition avant même de
l'avoir lu c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas
le sujet et palestiniens ont
l'impression qu'on les écoute pas au
niveau de la communauté internationale
et surtout ils ont l'impression que les
états unis ne leur laissent aucune place
en tant que peuple et nation donc
peut-être effectivement va-t-il y avoir
une augmentation des tensions ont
forcément des tensions et celle ci
attend avec impatience parce que cela
permet de renforcer leurs politiques de
féminisation qu'il n'avait pas d'autre
choix et que c'est les palestiniens qui
met israël dans une situation impossible
c'est vrai certains points de vue mais
il faut comprendre que les
collectionneurs sont également d'autres
situations possibles
ainsi il est très difficile de se mettre
d'un côté ou de l'autre il faut
simplement revenir à l'état de droit
alors vous le disiez mahmoud abbas
souhaite que l'onu se positionne comme
un médiateur dans ce dossier
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent également à
la place du plan de paix américain
concrètement je ne pense pas qu'il est
un plan je ne pense pas qu'il ait dit et
pourrait résoudre la solution
palestinienne
il n'y a pas une solution unique et cela
est dû au fait que au sein du monde
politique qui passe bien il ya beaucoup
de deux divisions très forte
certains moments sont presque des
élections
terroristes ou en tout cas ont été taxés
comme tel et la légitimité était
médiateur au niveau palestinien est très
difficile à établir un niveau
international
je pense que mahmoud abbas n'est pas une
posture parce qu'il n'a pas de véritable
le plan souvent les idées qu'il présente
sont rejetés de même par son propre
peuple et pour lui c'est très
déstabilisant au niveau domestique
niveau international
il n'a aucun cas aucune vision pour ce
que devrait être la palestine si ce
serait un étal 2 et à échanger tout tant
d'idées et il n'y a donc pas de
stabilité et pas de certitude selon sur
ses opinions
alors pour terminer le plan de paix
américain peut-il passer
peut-il être remanié largement remaniée
selon vous personnellement je ne
pourrais pas imaginer cette solution
mais donald trump a prouvé par le passé
et qui peut avoir des succès qu'on
pensait impossible au niveau de la
communauté internationale est assez
souvent c'est tentative hostile à ces
actes agressifs fonctionne pour lui donc
il pourrait effectivement y avoir une
solution qui passerait par la force et
les palestiniens seraient forcés de
tomber d'accord avec un compromis avec
israël afin de ne pas tout perdre et
benjamin netanyahu a menacé d'un excès
les colonies illégales de toute façon
qu'il voulait élargir son territoire de
toute façon qu'il voulait et dominèrent
ce qui reste de la palestine est donc
car de son point de vue ils n'ont pas de
territoire et non pas deux pays n'ont
pas de tradition
je ne pense pas que la communauté
internationale ou là
se poserait fortement à la maison
blanche en matière au point de vue
militaire ou diplomatique
et il est fort possible je pense que
cela serait dévastateur pour les
palestiniens que cela arrive de toute
façon merci beaucoup catherine chaque
manne pour votre analyse rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste du moyen-orient ce
mardi toujours aux états unis se tient
la primaire du new hampshire deuxième
étape dans le processus de désignation
du candidat démocrate qui affrontera
donald trump lors de la prochaine
présidentielle
l'objectif pour le parti démocrate
relever la tête après le fiasco du
caucus dans l'oural et lacheraf l'étape
du jour le new hampshire pour les
démocrates il s'agit de lancer la course
après l'embarrassant fiasco des caucus
de l'iowa à la semaine dernière un bug
de l'application utilisée pour la
collecte des résultats qui laissent
planer l'incertitude sur le classement
final des candidats
pitbull et jaden nouveau champion du
centre gauche on est sorti vainqueur in
extremis face à bernie sanders figurent
des démocrates
ce n'est pas seulement un auteur c'est
aussi un escroc donald trump naudy
chaque jour combien d'une seule chance
et haïr et craindre les sans papiers
mais en tant qu'homme d'affaires il a
engagé des centaines de sans papiers
pour travailler dans ces stations
balnéaires afin de pouvoir les exploiter
[Musique]
n'écouter personne qui affirme que vous
avez à choisir entre une stratégie pour
bien gouverner et une stratégie pour
gagner gros car ce qui va nous permettre
de gagner c'est de nous concentrer sur
l'avenir
c'est toujours comme ça qu'on gagne
quand nous décrochons la maison blanche
dans mon parti politiquement tout reste
à faire
la déconfiture dans l'iowa ont pêché
connaissent une forte dynamique de
campagne tandis que donald trump n'a
jamais semblé en si bonne posture depuis
son investiture
avec votre aide pour le trône au vent
on va vaincre les démocrates radicaux
socialistes on va gagner dans le new
hampshire de façon écrasante
[Applaudissements]
on a entendu que ça pourrait être parce
qu'il y à des croisements dans les
primaires n'est ce pas donc j'ai entendu
que beaucoup de républicains allaient
voter pour le candidat le plus faible
possible des démocrates
ça a du sens vous ne feriez pas ça mon
seul problème c'est que j'essaie de
trouver lequel est le candidat le plus
faible
je pense qu'ils sont tous faibles à
l'image de joe biden en petite forme
électorale pour le clan démocrate il ya
urgence à réagir
la premère du new hampshire pourrait
donc avoir de lourdes conséquences
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois durpaire historien et
spécialiste des états unis françois
durpaire bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors l'heure
est donc à la fois à la première
primaire démocrate dans le petit état du
new hampshire dans le nord-est des
etats-unis est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
vote crucial pour les candidats ça c'est
un peu comme les commentateurs sportifs
ils voudraient y voir tous les matches
comme des matches très importants
je vais un peu décevoir c'est pas
forcément le vote crucial c'est pas
forcément le moment qui va faire tout
basculer je vous donne un exemple pour
étayer un peu ma mon argumentation
si joe biden père dans le new york times
on pourra pas dire que thomas hayden qui
était encore favori il y a quelques
jours sera définitivement éliminé
pourquoi parce que joe biden son test ce
sera la caroline du sud
s'il perd en caroline du sud la wii joe
biden sera totalement éliminés et et
quid par exemple de bloomberg bloomberg
lui va intervenir qu'au moment du super
tuesday le 3 mars donc vous voyez c'est
un vote important qui va peut-être un
peu clarifié les choses mais c'est pas
le vote décisif s'est invité on l'a vu
dans la campagne avec un meeting
justement dans le new hampshire
ils sont tous faibles at-il décocher les
hostilités sont donc bien lancée oui
c'est à dire qu'en fait la stratégie de
d'un treuil
elle est très très clair il va aller je
vais utiliser une expression un peu un
petit peu populaire il va suivre à la
culotte les démocrates
si à qui vous savez qu'il ya une
primaire républicaine donc il va lui
faire sa primaire et vous avez vu que
son discours n'est pas un discours de
primaire ils sont intéressés et pas de
battre les autres républicains sait très
bien que c'est lui le candidat
républicain son intérêt c'est de montrer
aux électeurs que lui il est déjà dans
l'élection générale
il n'est pas dans l'élection primaire il
est dans l'élection générale et au
moment où eux sont en train de se battre
et bien lui il est en train de dire on
va remporter l'iowa on va remporter le
new york times il est déjà dans sa
campagne donc il est en train de prendre
un temps d'avancé sur les démocrates et
puis en fait ce qu'ils disent sur les
démocrates les démocrates le disent
eux-mêmes sur eux mêmes
vous entendez le débat télévisé thunders
trop à gauche c'est pas de d'un tram qui
le dit ce sont les autres démocrates by
donne trop establishment c'est pas by
donne qui le dis c'est pas ses patronnes
qui le dit ce sont les démocrates budget
drop et experts trop inexpérimenté ce
sont les démocrates qui le disent
etc etc alors dans le new hampshire est
ce que l'on peut s'attendre à un vote
similaire à celui de l'iowa la semaine
dernière à savoir un résultat très serré
pour entre petites boutiques djedj en
tête et bernie sanders tout juste
derrière ça change guère des sondeurs
arrive en tête dans les sondages dans
cette région oui alors bernie sanders
vous avez remarqué qu'il est en tête
dans le new hampshire et qu'il est
maintenant en tête dans le sondage
national il passe devant joe biden il
devient vraiment pour le moment en tout
cas le favori de cette campagne primaire
alors on peut penser que oui vous avez
raison ça sera peut-être à peu près le
même résultat que dans l'iowa pour
quelles raisons basse et la sociologie
du new hampshire
cet état dont on dit parfois qu'il est
le la
free or die tijd le l'état dû mourir
vivre libre ou mourir c'est un état qui
est très à gauche dans sa
circonscription nord un état ouvrier qui
pourrait donner savoir à saunders dans
le sud de l'état c'est en fait une
grande banlieue de boston et on peut
penser que la des zones périurbaines
pourrait voter pour beauty djedj donc on
pourrait effectivement avoir le même
vote alors à saunders un sud abouti dyed
et un bail d'un homme qui pourrait être
encore assez loin on pourrait encore
avoir c'est ces deux favoris mais
attention si demain on dit ccc beauty
djedj essais sanders qui gagne on pourra
pas dire comme il y a quatre ans comme
il ya huit ans voilà le duel qui nous
attend sa vie il ya toujours un duel
chez les démocrates
on a vu en 2008 obama versus clinton on
a vu en 2016 saunders versus clinton est
bien là on pourra pas dire demain ça
sera aboutie jays versus sanders parce
que c'est encore trop compliqué c'est
encore trop confus chez les démocrates
la vérité c'est que parmi les sept qui
était présent lors du débat de ce
week-end eh bien les 7 peuvent presque
encore se dire je vais gagner et cette
plus simple parce que bloomberg peut se
dire qu'il a aussi ses chances alors
vous parliez à l'instant de ce sondage
paru hier de l'université quinnipiac
pour la première fois vous lisiez bernie
sanders arrive devant joe biden est ce
que on peut parler d'un tournant
spectaculaire et si oui qu'est ce qu'il
révèle alors sanders il est très
clairement dans ce qu'on appelle aux
états unis le momentum
il est à pourrait d'ailleurs effectué la
passe de trois en emportant les trois
premiers états parce que vous savez qu
ensuite on va dans le nevada dans le
nevada les les syndicats sont très
importants et donc on a vraiment une
période très important pour % d'heures
alors évidemment ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir comment le finalement il
se reproduit un peu dans le parti
démocrate ce qui s'est produit à 4 ans
parti républicain c'est là que les
républicains qui se sont dit mais qu'est
ce qui est en train de se passer
mas c'est donald trump qui semble avoir
les faveurs des électeurs républicains
et la l'establishment républicain il
n'était pas très content de cette
situation là il ya même une guerre entre
l'establishment démocrate et sanders qui
a été déclarée la semaine dernière au
moment où tom perez le chef du parti
démocrate a demandé un recomptage dans
l'iowa sa sanders il n'a pas du tout
apprécié d'ailleurs il avait déjà
reproché un petit peu la cacophonie
il l'avait attribuée à ceux qui ont
élaboré
vous savez la fameuse application de
comptage des amis d'hillary clinton
comme par hasard qui a eu cette un peu
théorie du complot qui est arrivé en
tout cas cette opposition train tran est
en train sanders qui n'a pas les faveurs
de l'establishment mais qui pourrait
très bien avoir les faveurs des
électeurs démocrates alors toujours
d'après ce fameux sondages derrière eux
l'ex-maire de new york vous en parliez
bloomberg et qui bondit à la troisième
place avec une hausse remarquable par
rapport à janvier comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer cette poussée on respecte
de deux manières d'abord parce que c'est
les effets des premiers de ces preuves
de ses premières campagnes de publicité
il a investi énormément et on va voir
notamment reçu dans le moment du super
tuesday les effets de l'argent qu'ils
dépensent dans la campagne mais c'est
aussi sa stratégie qui est payant
puisque finalement au départ on se dit
c'est pas très malin de par venir dans
l'iowa ne pas venir dans le nu en chat
parce qu'il faut respecter la démocratie
d'ailleurs donald trump et et année dans
l'iowa mais il aurait très bien pu
commencer au super tuesday et finalement
et l'a77 ce bazar il faut bien dire au
sein du parti démocrate sert les
intérêts
de gluck baird qui finalement arrive
pour beaucoup d'électeurs comme une
sorte et biens de secours
et puis le deuxième atout de bloomberg
et bien c'est un peu la difficulté des
modérés et en particulier de baden
bloomberg il se situe au centre du parti
il est parrainé par la gauche et donc
joe biden apparaissant comme laissant la
place de se modérer il ya derrière
beauty jet mais comment va-t-il se
comporter dans les états du sud et
notamment avec les minorités il ya
également clos bouchard mais vous voyez
entre joe biden beauty jet clos bouchard
aucun de ces trois modérés ne parvient
vraiment à montrer sa capacité à
l'emporter et donc dans ce contexte là
blueberry l'arrêt il arrive comme un
candidat on dit aux états unis et
victimes veulent un candidat en mesure
de battre donald trump parce que c'est
la grande question en fait que se posent
tous et démocrates se pose même pas la
question de savoir quel sera le meilleur
président ou qu'elle est il celui qu'on
aime le plus
il se pose la question de quel est parmi
tous ceux là celui qui peut battre 2-1
trinque pour l'instant je veux bien dire
qu'ils sont un peu pessimiste et ils se
disent alors on n'a pas forcément de
grandes chances face à donald trump mais
attention une semaine en politique c'est
long on n'est pas encore au 3 devant
pourtant effectivement un toujours selon
l'université quinnipiac dans un éventuel
duel face à donald trump tous les
principaux candidats arriverait
vainqueur alors quelle valeur à cette
projection à plus de six mois du scrutin
vous savez sur les verts projection qui
effectivement je vous rappelle que laure
ya quatre ans dans les oppositions un
peu nationale comme ça sans prendre en
compte le chemin qui nous mène à
l'élection et à part peut-être pas mais
en prenant en compte uniquement le
sondage national
ils arrêtent layton l'emporter face à
donald trump pendant toute la campagne
aucun armement ou donna crown est apparu
devant hillary clinton
et pourtant vous savez que à la maison
blanche n'est pas hillary clinton s'est
bien donald trump
donc c'est son âge il faut les prendre
avec beaucoup de pincettes il faut
plutôt et
examinez le chemin qui va conduire à
l'éviction c'est à dire les scores que
pourrait faire d'un train dans le whisky
dans l'ohio en pennsylvanie en floride
c'est un état fédéral il faut vraiment
prendre en compte cette considération et
peut-être mettre de côté cette
opposition un peu factice de sondages
nationaux
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui donald trump
est à 49 % de popularité il n'a jamais
eu plus de 50%
et il ajoute d'ailleurs jamais gagné
avec 50 % donc il lui suffit finalement
de trouver un chemin dans ces états pour
l'emporter dans quelques mois
son atout principal étant évidemment la
bonne santé économique des etats-unis
63% des américains sont satisfaits de
l'économie et puis
va-t-il y avoir un effet acquittement
vous rappeler que bill clinton avait 72
% de popularité
juste après son acquittement et bien
donald trump pourrait aussi bénéficier
de ce2 ce2 cet acquittement et être être
renforcées dans les sondages d'opinion
merci beaucoup françois durpaire pour
votre analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et spécialiste des états unis
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur l' escalade meurtrière en syrie
entre les soldats turcs et les forces
loyales à bachar al assad qui se
poursuit à est libre puis direction le
liban où le parlement a accordé sa
confiance au nouveau
heureusement peu avant ce vote des
heurts ont éclaté entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre à rester avec nous sur
rtl
[Musique]
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans le sport que le
terme radicalisation c'est un peu un mot
valise et ont même beaucoup de choses
qui ne reflète pas la réalité dans part
de la radicalisation islamiste dans le
sport c'est tout ce processus qui peut
conduire quelqu'un à se mettre en marge
totale de la société parfois même
basculer vers l'action violente en 2016
au moins sportifs considéré que c'était
pas son affaire et qu'il n'avait pas
être une sorte de délateurs des pouvoirs
publics ce que le sujet c'est
qu'aujourd'hui toute une série de
phénomènes nous échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se créent
ou bien des structures qui se créent en
dehors du mouvement organisé
certains ont dit le sport amateur c'est
le premier lieu vecteur de
radicalisation c'est faux c'est la
prison dans les clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
mais pas contre les radicaliser ne vont
plus à la mosquée ne sont plus à l'école
ne sont plus dans les clubs
retirez vos de la tête que le sport
racialise
[Musique]
amna ne suis pas un terroriste high end
je ne suis pas un terroriste
je ne suis pas un terroriste de nos
jours peu importe où vous êtes
surveillés très probablement les drones
militaires ont fait des milliers de
morts innocents et peuvent attaquer à
tout moment n'importe où comme ils
veulent à plus de 10 mètres d'altitude
vous ne vous rendrez même temps que vous
êtes surveillés et en cas d' attaque
vous ne les voyez même pas
ward lire ce que nous avons vu dans le
scénario d'après le 11 septembre c'est
que dans le cas du pakistan la cia reçu
l'autorisation d'en tuer il bombarde des
villages il y à des villages des malades
des maisons parfois il déclare avoir
supprimé un terroriste et plus tard une
voie en vie alors qu'ils ont ils tué il
m'avait fait tuer des enfants pour le
pays fera fait pour le profit a aucune
comment pouvez-vous sourire
[Musique]
ici on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ceux qui six est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
chaque année 150 tonnes de déchets
électroniques sont amenés au ghana
c'est un travail dangereux mais nous
avons besoin d'argent
c'est pourquoi nous continuons à le
faire pour les pays développés
c'est le moyen le plus simple et le
moins coûteux de se débarrasser de ses
déchets toxiques
c'est une bombe à retardement si nous ne
trouvons pas de solution dans les deux
ou trois années à venir ce sera encore
pire et pour les habitants sur place
cette décharge est un aller simple vers
la mort cela veut dire que cette partie
d'accra sera tellement pollué
il faudra normalement poser une clôture
autour du site couler une chape de béton
dessus je vais créer un autre tchernobyl
accra
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'information
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
lé titre de l'actualité de ce mardi 11
février 2020
[Musique]
la turquie la firme plus de 150 soldats
syriens ont été neutralisés hier ankara
aurait répondu à l'offensive syrienne
aïd libre dans laquelle cinq militaires
turcs auraient péri elle les chiffres
n'ont pas été confirmés par damas pour
le moment l armée turque que ce serait
également attaqué à des blindés du camp
syrien recep tayyip erdogan a affirmé
que le pouvoir syrien paiera très cher
toute nouvelle attaque au liban un le
parlement accorde sa confiance au
nouveau gouvernement et ce malgré la
mobilisation de centaines de
manifestants a dès l'aube pour empêcher
les députés d'accéder au parlement dans
le centre-ville de beyrouth à les
manifestants dispersés par les forces de
l'ordre accuse les politiciens de
corruption généralisée et de mauvaise
gestion
[Musique]
l'heure des explications est une volonté
d'apaiser emmanuel macron re soit en ce
moment les députés après l'épisode du
congé pour deuil d'un enfant il ya
laissé un goût amer dans les rangs de la
majorité
alors que la république en marche voix
des parlementaires claqué la porte du
groupe sur fond de contestation de la
réforme des retraites
comment le président peut-il donner un
second souffle à son quinquennat à
l'acte ii at il explosé en vol avant
même de prendre vie ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
nouveaux affrontements meurtriers dans
la province d'idlib cet après-midi la
turquie a annoncé avoir frappé plus de
50 cibles de l'armée syrienne dans la
province du nord-est du pays à l'armée
syrienne tente quant à elle de reprendre
le dernier territoire encore aux mains
des djihadistes à des hostilités qui
accentuent la tension entre ankara et
damas les détails avec clément hospital
ces affrontements ont fait monter d'un
cran la tension entre les différents
acteurs présents militairement dans la
dèche un essai tayyip erdogan adressé un
ultimatum à la syrie lui demandant
d'éloigner ses troupes des postes
d'observation militaire turc d'ici la
fin février le gouvernement syrien reçu
un sérieux châtiment surtout à est libre
mais cela ne suffit pas il y aura une
suite car plus ils attaqueront nos
militaires
puis ils paieront cher très cher les
tensions entre ankara et damas ne semble
parti pour s'apaiser
une situation qui préoccupe le
secrétaire général de l'otan james
stoltenberg qui a exhorté les deux camps
à cesser les hostilités
je suis très préoccupé par la situation
à ed libre car nous avons été témoin d'
attaques horribles contre les civils
nous avons vu à nouveau que des
centaines de milliers de personnes ont
été forcées à fuir et nous avons
également vu des bombardements aveugles
de cibles civiles et nous condamnons
cela parce que nous condamnons également
les attaques aveugles contre des cibles
civiles s'imposant comme médiateur
incontournable du conflit syrien
la russie se dit elle aussi inquiète de
la situation et réclament l'arrêt de
toute activité terroriste dirigé contre
les installations militaires russes
nous pensons que maintenant le plus
important c'est le respect des accords
de sotchi c'était important et ça le
reste est aussi éliminé l'activité
terroriste dirigé contre les forces
armées syriennes et les infrastructures
militaires russes nous considérons que
de telles offensives depuis yves ils
sont inacceptables
selon l'onu près de sept cent mille
personnes ont été déplacées dans le nord
ouest du pays depuis début décembre
la turquie redoute que l'offensive de
damas ne provoque une nouvelle vague
migratoire vers la turquie où plus de
trois millions et demi de syriens ont
trouvé refuge depuis 2011
1 pour en parler nous sommes avec randa
kassis président de la plateforme
d'astana auteurs de l' ouvrage la syrie
et le retour de la russie aux éditions
des syrtes randa kassis bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait selon la turquie au moins 150
soldats de l'armée syrienne aurait été
neutralisé par l'armée turque
quelle valeur apportée à ces
déclarations il est vrai que le
président turc erdogan va continuer
toutes façons d'abord pas que continuer
son sens et à l'intérieur de la syrie
mais aussi d' à continuer à armer les
rebelles en syrie
en fait qui se trouve dans la province
d'idleb et de l'est pas et réciproque ça
va être aussi la russie qui va soutenir
le régime syrien
en espérant bien sûr de lutter contre
les terroristes mais bien sûr pour le
régime syrien s'est pas que les
terroristes mais c'est aussi ce qu'ils
veulent c'est la reprise de la province
d'idleb pour avoir le contrôle sur le
sur l'ensemble de territoire syrien
alors après comment ça va être c'est une
escalade et façon pour moi je laisse
était vraiment prévisible tout cela la
corde sotchi je peux le dire et c'est
une déclaration en fait c'est plutôt si
même
un état de léthargie c'est la mort de
cet accord là il y aura il y aura je
vois pas comment les deux pays la russie
et la turquie vont continuer à faire
semblant d'avoir une vraie alliance une
collaboration sur le territoire syrien
puis à vrai dire la vérité il n'ya pas
ça n'existe pas cette collaboration
pourquoi parce que les intérêts de des
deux pays sont différents et j'ai un
indice tensions sur pas mal de points
sur le processus politique sur 20 sur
pour définir d'abord qui sont les
terroristes la turquie ne considère pas
les islamistes radicaux comme des
terroristes que c'est pas le cas pour la
russie alors il y avait vraiment un vrai
dissensions moi je crois que la nuance
qui a été fait il ya quelques temps
c'était une alliance tout simplement me
nécessaire une alliance de survie est ce
que cette alliance va continuer à vrai
dire ou même historiquement si on voit
l'histoire entre la russie et à l'époque
notamment aux ottomans c'était toute
façon il y avait toujours une histoire
qui était pleine de guerre et de l entre
les deux est historiquement je crois que
ça dessine 6 2
les relations dans le futur proche
entre ces deux pays cette attaque
turquie est une réponse à une attaque
présumée de damas dans laquelle cinq
militaires turcs présents dans un poste
d'observation auraient péri à lille peut
être rappeler nous pourquoi l'armée
turque est elle toujours présente en
syrie si aujourd'hui à vrai dire déjà
c'était une grosse erreur pour moi
d'accepter l'offensive turque dans le
territoire syrien dans le nord pour je
parle bien sûr dans le nord est ce ça
c'était la première erreur deuxième
erreur il
il ne fallait pas aussi accepté que le
régime géré jaune reprenait quelques
reprenez quelques endroits quelques
villes clés dont le nombre est de toute
façon
malheureusement il n'y a pas de
processus en voit très bien qu'il n'ya
pas de processus politique le comité ce
qu'on appelle le comité constitutionnel
c'est rien toute façon c'est un comité
qui est vouée à l'échec depuis très
longtemps je l' ai déjà dit depuis pas
mal de temps et rien qui est étonnante
façon il n'y eu pas de processus les
intérêts ne sont pas les mêmes la
turquie veut rester en série au moins
elle veut préserver préserver son armée
ou aussi ses mercenaires syrien qui
travaillent pour elles dans le nord de
la syrie ce qui va pas fonctionner le
régime aussi il veut avoir le contrôle
qui ne comprend pas jusqu'aujourd'hui
qu'il ya une nécessité vraiment de faire
ou de 2,2 de travailler sérieusement sur
un processus politique raisonnable et
réaliste
alors je vois pas comment on va on va
sortir on arrivera à sortir de tout de
ce cas le l'onu malheureusement vous
voyez très bien que l'onu est très
faible mais dassin toute façon il ne
peut rien faire il peut faire peut-être
l'humanitaire come back to norvégien un
bon norvégien ne sait faire que ça ne
peut faire que ça à vrai dire peut-être
été aussi prendre quelques sacs de riz
pour pour les distribuer aux réfugiés
comme un comme bernard kouchner l'a fait
dans le passé alors malheureusement
c'est ça la situation avec l'onu il n'y
aura rien de tout on aurait vraiment on
a cru d'avoir touché le fond avec ban ki
moon et à aider mistura mais on a
tellement creuser encore et encore parce
que en dessous
et à trouver de pétrole mais à la place
on a trouvé un but et res et pedersen
randa kassis de son côté pour bien
comprendre quel est l'objectif de
l'armée syrienne dans la région d'idlib
aujourd'hui le comme je les dis le
régime syrien et veut avoir le contrôle
toute façon sur l'ensemble de territoire
syrien pourquoi parce qu'il ne souhaite
pas avoir un procès un processus
politique en serre et pour lui c'est
toujours la solution il y dit il et
jusqu'aujourd'hui il croit que la
solution militaire est la seule solution
et ils se croient vainqueur et c'est ça
le problème les dents un dans un état de
d'esprit schizophrène je peux l'appeler
comme d'ailleurs le cas de notre
position qu'on l'appelle snc la
coalition syrienne où les autres de le
comité où le ce qu'on appelle le comité
des négociations
ils sont tous tous ces gens là ils sont
toujours dans le même esprit qui sont
déconnectés de la réalité
et chacun il croire les autres qui
croient que à led avec l'est de la
turquie et l'arabie saoudite
ils peuvent s'imposer pour avoir quelque
chose ou revenir en série pour avoir le
pouvoir le régime aussi quoique avec une
solution militaire
il arriva à avoir gardé le contrôle et
après bien sûr il souhaite la levée des
sanctions économiques et c'est
impossible il n'aura pas de levée des
sanctions économiques il n'y aura pas de
reconstruction en syrie alors pour moi
toute façon le
tout ça va durer tout ça va durer que
même pour pas mal de temps et la russie
ne pourra rien faire malheureusement en
tous les cas est ce qu'il ya un dialogue
entre damas ankara sur les opérations
menées dans la région d'idlib
oui ils ont essayé à l'aide de la russie
mais est ce que vraiment c'était
efficace moi je crois pas parce que déjà
il n'est pas un entente entre la russie
et la turquie
comme je les dis il ya pas mal de
dissension d'abord il faut définir qui
sont les terroristes qui comme je les
dis erdogan considèrent même les
islamistes radicaux ne sont pas des
terroristes les autres considèrent que
même celui qui a porté ou qui portent
une arme ou qui souhaiteraient même pas
porter une arme même un opposant
politique qui souhaitent avoir de
changement en syrie et à voir ce
processus politique est un terroriste
alors je vois pas comment les deux pays
où nous je veux dire le régime syrien et
le gouvernement turc pourrait se mettre
d'accord sur des points communs alors
une dernière question une délégation
russe se trouvait à ankara pour des
pourparlers visant à trouver une
solution aux affrontements à idlib après
ce nous ce nouvel échange d'hostilité
s'il est confirmé est ce que ces
pourparlers risquent d'être remises en
cause
c'est une remise en cause avaient adhéré
on sait pas ce qui s'est passé ça veut
dire moi continue n'y a pas un un des
mots clairs d'aider un communiqué qui
est clair ça veut dire que personne
façon les deux copains sont pas mis
d'accord
comme je les dis ils vont essayer de
faire semblant et de sauver la face
c'est à dire de garder ses alliances au
minimum mais ce peut être après quelques
temps toute façon il y aura même pas
cette alliance et les relations vont
redevenir comme avant c'est à dire
en 2015 c'était en 2015 2016
et ça va être ce il escalade peut-être
entre les deux pays
merci beaucoup randa kassis d'avoir
partagé votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes présidente de la plateforme
d'astana et auteur du livre la syrie et
le retour de la russie aux éditions des
syrtes
au liban le parlement accorde sa
confiance au nouveau gouvernement après
une journée sous haute tension dans le
pays
depuis ce matin des manifestants se sont
réunies à beyrouth ce devant le
parlement le premier ministre hassan
diab il présentait son programme
politique et économique
une feuille de route rejetée par les
libanais et les forces de l'ordre ont dû
faire usage de gaz lacrymogènes et de
canons à eau pour déloger les
protestataires depuis le mois d'octobre
le pays est en proie à un mouvement de
contestation inédit qui fustige
l'ensemble de la classe au pouvoir
accusé de corruption et d'incompétence
explications de walid benes
des gaz lacrymogènes des canons à eau
pour tenter de faire fuir les
manifestants
mardi matin les voies se sont de nouveau
élevées dans la capitale libanaise lieu
de rassemblement et de contestation le
parlement les politiciens ont élevé des
murs anti souffle
ils ont fait venir des forces de
sécurité et il me semble qu'ils sont
terrifiés par ce qu'il se passe et je
pense que chaque jour la révolution est
plus fort que une feuille de route des
cimes et la semaine dernière mais une
équipe peu loin de faire l'unanimité
[Applaudissements]
nous demandons des réformes aux hommes
politiques que nous puissions au moins
nous nourrir une revendication un droit
fondamental tapé sur des casseroles
permet de se relâcher comme quelqu'un
qui frappe du pied au sol pour se
défouler nous sommes soumis à une
pression énorme et nous essayons de la
relâcher en tapant sur des casseroles
depuis près de quatre mois semaine après
semaine beyrouth est le théâtre
d'affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre
les libanais accusé la classe dirigeante
de corruption et d'incompétence
les heurts qui ont fait plusieurs
centaines de blessés en pousser saad
hariri à démissionner de son poste de
premier ministre le 29 octobre dernier
aujourd'hui son successeur doit
redresser un pays miné par une crise
économique mais également faire face à
un problème de légitimité mais la
légitimité d'alassane diab pose problème
cette session parlementaire est
illégitime
comment accepterons-nous un premier
ministre qui a fait partie d'un
gouvernement divisé il ya cinq ou six
ans
assane thiam n'a pas été en mesure de
nommer un ministre jusqu'à ce qu'il
demande l'aval du président les dames
ancien premier ministre j'ai besoin
justement d'un premier ministre
indépendant d'un ministre indépendant et
non d'un étudiant qui acceptent des
ordres de qui que ce soit licenciements
en masse restrictions banca drastique
taxe sur la téléphonie ou encore
dépréciation de la monnaie du pays en
le gouvernement prévoit une coupe dans
les dépenses de plus de 640 millions
d'euros
le temps est venu qu'ils comprennent que
ces personnes ne délaisseront pas les
rues notre révolution continuera jusqu'à
ce qu'il parte
notre but est la révolution révolution
et révolution aujourd'hui le liban à
l'une des dettes publiques les plus
élevées au monde
82 milliards d'euros soit plus de 150%
du pib et pour maya khadra journaliste
et membre fondateur du forum académique
chrétiens pour la citoyenneté dans le
monde arabe
la confiance accordée du parlement au
gouvernement en place n'est pas une
surprise écouter ya pas de surprise
évidemment parce que le quorum a été
atteint vers 11h45 aujourd'hui donc il y
avait une véritable volonté surtout chez
les blocs parlementaires qui appuient
hassan diab et qui sont les blocs je
dirais anti souverainiste vivent et qui
qui ont contribué beaucoup à la
corruption et à l'état délétère dans
lequel le pays patauge depuis plus de
cent jours et depuis plus de deux
décennies aussi je dirais cette
confiance aujourd'hui n'a aucune
validité sur un plan populaire sur le
plan populaire je pense que il ya un
véritable rejet de la classe politique
est un véritable rejet aussi du
parlement des plus grands blocs
parlementaires qui eux ont tout limité
le pouvoir que ce soit économique
politique aussi dans leur parti donc
évidemment confiance au niveau du
parlement mais méfiance totale et pour
moi je m'attends à une escalade de
violence aussi dans les rues
du liban cette feuille de route elle
n'est pas différente des feuilles de
route des différents gouvernements qui
ont failli à renflouer l'économie
libanaise et a relevé le liban de la
crise dans laquelle de laquelle il est
prisonnier en fait la feuille c'est
toujours la même on parle c'est laisser
les mêmes discours en bois les mêmes
discours qui n'évolue pas qu'ils ne
proposent pas de solutions qui sont plus
littéraire que pragmatique et je vais
vous donner quelques preuves donc le
droit du peuple libanais a résisté
ça se contredit totalement avec l'idée
cité dans dans ce même dans ce même
manifes ou dans ce même discours du du
gouvernement libanais qui dit que le
liban devrait être neutre
comment on plaide pour la neutralité du
liban et on invite les libanais à
résister contre israël est donc on sait
très bien au liban que quand on appelle
à résister contre israël ça sous-entend
aussi soutenir tous les régimes dans la
région que ce soit le régime iranien
c'est le hesbollah que ça soit le régime
syrien bachar al assad ou autre régime
aussi donc hissé c'est vraiment c'est un
c'est un coup dur pour la neutralité du
liban
donc ça c'est sur un plan politique sur
le plan financier il ya aucune réforme
concrète qui a été avancé dans ce bilan
ils ont dit que oui ils vont peut-être
adopté quelques conseils dans le plan
mckenzie qui a été proposé l'année
dernière pour sortir de la crise du
liban mais aucune de ces relevés la
réforme n'a été cité dans ce document
sur un autre plan aussi
il y à une adoption qui l'ère des mêmes
solutions bien du même plan qui est
appelé le plan boost amis c'est le plan
qui gère tout ce qui est énergétiquement
et surtout le secteur de l'électricité
au liban le même plan qui est
responsable de plus de 55 % de la dette
du liban est adopté
c'est scandaleux et c'est indécent
l'aide extérieure ça sera une aide qui
sera qui va aller directement dans les
poches des mêmes personnes
la d'extérieur si elle ne s'applique pas
sur des réformes des réformes concrètes
elle est vaine parce que le liban reçoit
des aides extérieures depuis des années
et des années qui devient la première
éruption en revient au problème de la
corruption
on revient aussi à ce système qui est
complètement délétère et qu'il favorise
même la corruption parce qu'on ne peut
pas oublier que par exemple le port au
liban et tout ce qui est tout ce qui se
rapporte à la douane s'est tenu par deux
trois personnes que ce soit nabih berri
que ça soit le hezbollah en parlant du
port et de l'aéroport
walid joumblatt est une figure de la
corruption aussi
pendant les années 90 et jusqu'à
maintenant même donc le liban est
vraiment captif de plusieurs personnes
qui le tiennent en otage et qui cherche
toujours à alimenter un certain discours
qui dresse les communautés les unes
contre les autres pour garder cette
position de force dans la rue libanaise
là actuellement il n'y a pas que des
manifestants venant des des classes
défavorisées et au liban au contraire il
ya beaucoup de personnes valables il ya
des personnes qui ont des diplômes il ya
des personnes qui ont même des
programmes politiques qui écrivent dans
les journaux on n'oublie pas qu'au liban
enfin le il ya 99% de personnes les
traits c'est un pays où le haut le
secteur éducatif est très important il
est très évoluée le liban paraît dans
l'est dans les classements mondiaux sur
le sur le plan éducatif engagé dans la
vie politique alors ce n'est pas une
priorité pour le moment parce que
justement les revendications du peuple
libanais c'est en premier lieu de placer
des technocrates dans le gouvernement et
même délire des technocrates au
parlement pour sortir de la crise après
on pourrait passer au discours politique
idéologique au véritable sens du terme
pour apaiser la rue libanaise il y à une
solution démocratique très légitime est
très logique actuellement c'est
d'organiser des législatives anticipées
parce qu'on est vraiment dans un cul de
sac sur le plan démocratique le peuple
n'est pas représenté au parlement dans
la rue libanaise là actuellement il n'y
a pas que des manifestants
venant des classes défavorisées au liban
au contraire il ya beaucoup de personnes
valeur il ya des personnes qui ont des
diplômes il ya des personnes qui ont
même des programmes politiques qui
écrivent dans les journaux on n'oublie
pas qu'au liban enfin le il ya 99% de
personnes les traits c'est un pays où le
haut le secteur éducatif est très
important il est très évoluée le liban
paraît dans les dans les classements
mondiaux sur le engagés dans la ville
classique jean qu'engagé dans la vie
politique alors ce n'est pas une
priorité pour le moment parce que
justement les revendications du peuple
libanais c'est en premier lieu de placer
des technocrates dans le gouvernement et
même délire des technocrates au
parlement pour sortir de la crise après
on pourrait passer au discours politique
idéologique au véritable sens du terme
l'iran célèbre aujourd'hui le 41e
anniversaire de la révolution islamique
une marée humaine a envahi les rues du
pays pour fêter cet événement un
anniversaire qui coïncide avec le 40ème
jour de l'assassinât du général qasem
soleimani par les etats-unis en irak
de nombreux slogans anti américains et
anti israéliens ont retenti ce à téhéran
aujourd'hui c'est aussi le quarantième
jour qui suit la mort du général
sulejmani nous sommes ici pour dire que
nous poursuivrons son action et nous
devons adresser à l'amérique une ou deux
gifles
nous sommes ici pour gifler nos ennemis
en plein visage
l'amérique israël et le royaume uni les
états unis ne peuvent rien offert à
travers leurs sanctions
même si nous mourrons de faim et de
pauvreté nous ne feront certainement pas
de compromis avec eux je le dis aux
autorités aux étrangers et aux états
unis
trump qui nous tend la main au geste
d'amitié puis tu assassines autre grand
général et tu considère ça comme une
victoire
tu es trop désespéré pour mettre diront
à genoux et de son côté le président
iranien hassan rohani en a profité pour
dénoncer la politique des états unis
écoutez le il est insupportable pour les
états unis d'accepter la victoire d'une
grande nation etc une superpuissance
étaient chassés de cette terre et dans
quelques instants notre débat sur le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron le
président peut-il trouver un nouveau
souffle l'acte ii est il vraiment lancé
nous en débattrons avec nos invités
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
il faut bien comprendre que les champs
de schiste pétroliers américains donc
quelque temps vont s'arrêter de produire
violer toutes les données pétrolières
sont confidentielles
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme
avec le pétrole de schiste les
américains soient énergétique
indépendant banon ils sont en train de
frôler indépendance mais pour le pour le
gars cynisme en mai pour le pétrole
non c'est puis là le puits de schiste
sont des puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle
si les pétroles de schiste des cent
cette année suffisamment pour que ça
square notable en moins devant moi tron
ne sera pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok je dois admettre avec regret que le
taux de suicide dans notre pays est très
élevé
[Musique]
il est monté je crois au 13e étage de
son immeuble et il a sauté un suicide
semblable a eu lieu trois jours plus
tard le 28 décembre
vous savez sans doute que d'après les
statistiques les gens se suicident y
majoritairement à 20 ans j'ai pensé que
ce serait bien que les jeunes sur le
point de se suicider viennent ici venir
mana que pour voir ce qu'est la mort
pour comprendre l'importance de ce
qu'ils ont dans la khl au dos et au cou
de niro
[Musique]
et
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits coups politiques n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des guignols aujourd'hui on a une
gauche extrêmement tous les témoins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview il y a une problématique
d'augmentation extrêmement importante de
la demande en eau depuis la révolution
verte qui a conduit à cette
autosuffisance alimentaire de l'inde
dans ces zones climatiques aride il ya
quasiment plus d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
pomper ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image une femme qui porte un pot à
eau sur la tête est une image que l'on
voit partout
pour les femmes c'est une charge énorme
des petites filles peuvent pas aller à
l'école parce qu'elles doivent aider à
cette tâche par exemple donc ça accentue
des inégalités 85% de l'eau consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pour être produite à l'échelle mondiale
d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire l'eau qui
est contenu dans les produits qui sont
échangées l'inde est un des plus gros
exportateurs d'eau donc c'est un
paradoxe c'est un paradoxe lensois
[Musique]
oui c'est comme si j'étais passé à une
autre époque les cadettes un peu de nerf
c'est quoi ce chaos
je suis plus une personne de la terre et
aujourd'hui j'ai quitté la maison pour
aller en mer c'est moi le maître du
perroquet bordel
[Musique]
regardez c'est pas croyable
je ne pensais pas être aussi forte avant
même une barque sur une rivière
j'aurais eu peur de me noyer mais
maintenant je m'en fiche
on ne va pas couler avec ce bateau enfin
si tu le veux
[Musique]
21h30 heure de paris soyez les bienvenus
en direct sur rt france merci de nous
rejoindre
opération déminage pour le président
emmanuel macron il reçoit en ce moment
les députés de la majorité
unité et cohésion sont les mots d'ordre
affiché pour cette soirée avec un
échange direct selon l'elysée après
plusieurs couacs notamment celui du
congé pour deuil d'enfant mais aussi sur
fond de réforme de retraite pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons devant
l'elysée notre reporter katia technique
les députés sont arrivés peu avant 20
heures à l'elysée dans un long ballet de
voitures
la presse a parlé de calinothérapie en
évoquant cette entrevue pourquoi et bien
parce qu'il ya de nombreuses tensions
depuis plusieurs semaines on se souvient
de ce vote de la majorité contre
l'allongement du congé en cas de deuil
d'un enfant
eh bien il n'avait fait que suivre les
consignes du parti
or face au tollé emmanuel macron les
avait exhortés à faire preuve de
davantage d'humanité
ces remarques ont été très mal perçue
par les députés qui se sont sentis
trahis alors maintenant il va falloir
résoudre ce couac
ajoutons à cela que les députés doivent
maintenir le cap de la réforme des
retraites contre vents et marées quand
bien même elle serait mal perçu dans
leur circonscription il ya aussi le
contexte de la bataille des municipales
qui est très féroce avec une opposition
très forte certaines permanences de
députés ont été vandalisés et puis même
au sein de l'assemblée nationale il ya
des dissensions certains parlementaires
reproche à d'autres de ne pas être assez
proche du terrain ou encore d'être trop
poseur de la présidence il y a également
les députés qui étaient originellement à
gauche qui peuvent regretter l'inflexion
prises pour la politique du gouvernement
et puis de manière générale les
parlementaires reprocherait à emmanuel
macron d'être trop distant c'est
seulement la troisième fois qu'il les
reçoit à l'elysée depuis le début de son
mandat
on sait que le président n'aime pas les
dissensions alors il évoquera
certainement le cas de la dizaine de
députés qui ont quitté le groupe
lrm à l'assemblée nationale alors est ce
que cette entrevue sera une séance de
calinothérapie ou un conseil de
discipline en tout cas pas sûr que le
député apprécié le mariage du
et du froid au cours de ce rendez vous
alors on le disait emmanuel macron
reçoit en ce moment même les députés de
la majorité pour retisser des liens
après l'épisode du congé pour deux
enfants qui a laissé un fort
ressentiment
le président peut-il trouver un nouveau
souffle dans cette dernière partie de
son quinquennat
l acte ii annoncés at il explosé en vol
avant même de prendre vie c'est l'objet
de notre face à face et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec gilles casanova
consultant en stratégie et communication
bonsoir soins à vos côtés stéphane rozès
président de cap c'est le conseil
analyse et protée perspective enseignant
à sciences po et hec alors pour
commencer cette opération apaisement le
président hu elle mêle macron il n'avait
pas le choix
selon vous où ils avaient tous les choix
de toute façon dans sa situation il a
une grande liberté dans la mesure où
elle est suffisamment difficile pour
qu'on puisse penser qu'il n'ya pas une
manière de faire il y en a visiblement
plusieurs mais la difficulté qu'il
montre c'est quelque chose qu'il avait
utilisé comme un atout d'ailleurs que
les français avaient pour un certain
nombre d'entrevues comme sympathique
il n'était pas un politique il n'avait
même pas été conseiller municipal
donc ils n'allaient pas tomber dans les
travers des politiciens le problème ce
fait qu' il n'a du coup jamais parlé à
ses électeurs
il n'a jamais siégé dans des assemblées
il n'a jamais participé à autre chose
dans l'état que des symposiums de
technocrates qui considère que les
assemblées élues sont des empêcheurs de
tourner en rond qui empêche les gens qui
savent de faire ce qu'ils savent faire
et là il se trouve confronté au fait que
malgré tous ses efforts pour réformer la
constitution est retirée aux
parlementaires une partie significative
leurs droits cette réforme n'a pas eu
lieu
et même si le parlement n'est pas un
lieu qui a un très grand pouvoir du -
existe-t-il est il obligé de faire avec
sa majorité et il s'est rendu compte que
lorsqu'on dit à sa majorité de faire une
chose puis que le patron du medef vous
dire ah bah non ça c'est vraiment
inhumain on qu'on est obligé de dire aux
médias ouais c'est vraiment inhumain là
la majorité est bien la majorité elle ne
fonctionne pas toujours le petit doigt
sur la couture du pantalon
surtout pour une raison quand on a perdu
dans les sondages
la garantie de les faire élire stéphane
rozès vous partagez la proche de gilles
casanova justement sur cette réunion les
raisons de la convocation de cette
réunion ce soir par emmanuel macron il y
a effectivement des raisons profondes
une quinzaine de députés qui ont quitté
le groupe la république en marche dans
les 50 premières villes des dissensions
dans le tiers de ces villes
donc la majorité parlementaire et ceux
qui sont au contact du terrain ont du
vague à l'âme parce que justement étant
en contact avec le terrain effectivement
ils doivent rendre compte d'une
cohérence et d'une utilité de l'action
menée par l'exécutif
or il ya eu le mouvement social le plus
long soutenu par l'opinion jusqu'à la
fin même si c'était moi c'est important
qu'ils étaient les gigues et chou qui
était une sorte de ruche et à cri qui
s'adressait au président mais dont
évidemment les députés sur le terrain du
donner des éléments d'explication mais
ce n'était pas simple et puis une
réforme des retraites toujours toujours
qu'il va passer du fait des institutions
mais dont toujours deux tiers des
français montrent leur opposition
donc évidemment la macro ni est en
difficulté parce que au fond c'est le
lien entre le président et le pays qui
s'est délitée à partir de l'été 2010 8
alors on le sait les institutions de la
vème république donne effectivement une
grande latitude au président pour
avancer et le sujet c'est au tour de
votre question sur le rebond c'est que
pense faire encore le président de la
république après après les municipales
on attendait cette réforme des retraites
plus tôt avant les municipales
après pardon qu'est ce que ça veut dire
que ça a été ramenée avant les
municipales est ce que c'était une façon
d'éclusés ou de faire passer des
messages ou centre-droit donc on
comprend que dans la vision
présidentielle c'est le socle électoral
sur lequel il pourrait s'appuyer aux
municipales en hameaux dans un pays
comme le nôtre l'autonomie du sommet de
l'état et des institutions donne de très
grande marge de manoeuvre
même si le pays peut être dans un état
de tension et de violence rarement connu
ces dernières décennies donc au fond si
le président pense aller jusqu'à la
présidentielle comme ça il peut user de
d'éléments de communication le sujet csq
après la réforme des retraites il
souhaite faire à nouveau une réforme
structurelle alors on a les premières
réactions à les premiers propos qui ont
été dits par le président emmanuel
macron ce soir il a exhorté les députés
la république en marche à l'unité il
s'est défendu de tout caporalisme est ce
que cette soirée de ce soir peut marquer
un tournant
un second souffle selon gilles casanova
non il n'y a absolument aucune raison
qu'une rencontre entre le président et
les députés de sa majorité puisse aux
yeux des français incarner un second
souffle
parce que c'est pas là que se situe le
problème des français les français ils
ont vu dans ces manuels mâcon une
pochette surprise aux couleurs
chamarrées chatoyantes au premier tour
un peu plus de 15% des français en âge
de voter ont voté pour lui et au second
tour une majorité lafay président de la
république mais une majorité du pays à
ce moment là à penser qu'il y avait
quelque chose à voir et à découvrir dans
cet homme qui était hors du jeu des
appareils qui était tout à fait
différent qui était autre chose
et puis au fur et à mesure ils ont
ouvert la pochette surprise et ces
derniers mois ce qui a été terrible pour
lui c'est que ce qui est apparu c'est
qu'il n'était pas à la hauteur des
espoirs
par exemple quand le conseil d'état dit
que la réforme des retraites telle
qu'elle est présentée au parlement c'est
ni fait ni à faire lorsque il retoque
profondément la circulaire du ministre
de l'intérieur pour organiser les
élections municipales
lorsque des députés de la république en
marche s'en vont les uns après les
autres
lorsque des affaires comme la sphère
benalla éclate c'est autre chose que
l'orientation politique qui est en cause
c est il bien capable d'être à la place
où on l'a mis or on se souvient qu on
l'a mis pour que madame le pen n'y soit
pas du moins c'est le cas de la majorité
des électeurs du second tour et
maintenant ils se disent est ce que
c'est lui qui est capable de prendre en
main notre destin d'une façon positive
même si on n'a pas voté pour lui et ce
qui apparaît c'est qu'aujourd'hui ceux
qui n'ont pas voté pour lui
non plus un avis très positif sur sa
capacité à mener le pays
est ce que stéphane rozès vous rejoignez
ce constat jill casanova qui dit au fond
1 que les couacs qu'on a pu vivre les
difficultés que la france est temps de
lire c'est à cause du président la
république et non pas dans éventré
l'amateurisme des députés ou d'un manque
d'expérience des députés
je suis d'accord pour dire peu comme
emmanuel macron s'est fait élire dans un
moment bonapartiste ou des français
souhaitaient que les grands arbitrages
ne se passe plus dans les corps
intermédiaires ou au parlement mais dans
un lien direct entre le président et de
français puisque les français le
président disait c'est pas vous les
français des responsables de notre
malheur vous n'avez pas intériorisé une
culpabilité ou un problème c'est le
personnel politique
je sais j'en viens et donc je vais
dépasser des anciens clivages et c'est
dans ma relation à vous que des choses
vont s'opérer c'est la forme
traditionnelle du bonapartisme adapté
aux moments néolibérale donc on peut
dire nés au bonapartisme
alors là où j'ai je suis un peu en
désaccord avec gilles casanova sait que
c'est bien des questions d'orientation
qui fait qu'à un moment le pays n'a plus
consentis car le président macron
s'était fait élire en disant devant le
congrès le premier mandat de me confier
des français c'est de restaurer la
souveraineté de la nation
de sorte que le programme qui était le
sien était dès le départ et jugé
injustes socialement mais des français
il consentait parce que la question de
la restauration de la souveraineté
nationale qui sont nationales prévalait
sur la question sociale
et quant à partir du printemps angela
merkel lui dit
qu'elle ne va pas offrir à emmanuel
mâcon le deuxième étage de la fusée qui
est de desserrer des politiques
européennes pour donner des marges de
manoeuvre à la réforme qu emmanuel
macron appelé à bucarest en disant que
la france ne fonctionnait pas par des
réformes imposées de l'extérieur mais
emmanuel macron revient aux propos de
ses prédécesseurs de sorte que ce qui
était accepté avant durant la réforme du
travail du code du travail ou la réforme
de la sncf que des français auquel les
français ne se posait pas alors même
qu'il disait que la politique est
injuste socialement
ce qui était admis avant ne pouvait pas
l'être après puisqu'au fond il reprenait
la politique de ses prédécesseurs que
lui même avait dénoncé à bucarest le
fétichisme budgétaire la politique du
rabot la politique imposée de
l'extérieur et à partir de ce moment là
le maquereau nisme ceux d'édith dans sa
justification première ce qui lui a pu
étonner des observateurs c'est qu'au
fond après les gilets jaunes
le président macron avec la réforme des
retraites mène une réformes
structurelles d'ampleur alors même que
son lien avec le pays est absolument
distendus il a réussi avec le grand
débat à renouer un tout petit peu mais
pas suffisamment comme si au total et
c'est ça qui devrait nous interroger g15
nava et moi comme s'il se constatait et
se contentait de constater qu hormis
marine le pen qui attend tapi la
présidentielle il n'avait toujours pas
dans le pays
d'opposition politique ou de front
syndical suffisamment fort pour faire
tenir une grève bloquant le pays comme
en 95
alors que l'opinion est toujours deux
tiers opposé cette réforme gîte à
continuer d'asseoir le débat entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron c'est
le soient c'est l'objectif
du chef de l'état oui c'est très
clairement son assurance vie politique
tant qu'il sera opposée à marine le pen
ils pensent qu'il se trouvera toujours
une majorité pour le préféré il y a
maintenant quelque chose qui entrent
dans l'équation qui est que pour être
opposée à marine le pen il faut être au
second tour or c'est cela qui
aujourd'hui devient un problème
vous avez peut-être noté que dans deux
des instituts qui mesure chaque mois la
popularité sous une forme ou sous une
autre du président de la république il a
atteint exactement le même niveau que
françois hollande à la même date de fond
de son mandat c'est à dire que s'ouvre
l'hypothèse qu'ils ne soient pas en
position de se représenter ou pas en
position de figurer au second tour
pour vous il ne sera pas je ne suis pas
voyant extra lucide et tous ceux qui se
sont hasardés a annoncé que balladur
était élu que juppé était président que
bat rethel nouveaux présidents ont bien
vu que tout ça n'existait pas mais il ya
une chose que l'on peut dire c'est que
l'idée qu'il est le seul qui peut battre
marine le pen c'est une idée qui s'est
renversée c'est au contraire aujourd'hui
celui qui apparaît le plus affaibli face
à marine le pen des candidats potentiels
alors les candidats potentiels se sont
pas forcément ceux qui vont sur les
chaînes d'information dire qu'ils y
pensent en se rasant les jambes ou les
joues mais des personnes qui ne sont pas
forcément aujourd'hui dans le jeu mais
qui peuvent surgir parce qu'il ressent
parce qu'ils représentent des secteurs
réelle du pays même si ils ne sont pas
forcément là encore le produit de
l'histoire des grands partis qui sont
durablement affaibli est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la république en marche
stéphane rozès est réellement en danger
députés aujourd'hui 314 départ donc
parce qu'il ya un véritable danger pour
la majorité aujourd'hui qu'elle perde sa
majorité parlementaire sans doute part
parce que quand même il ya beaucoup de
députés qui sont conscients qu'ils ne
sont là que par la grâce du président et
que au fond dans la victoire
présidentielle d'emmanuel mâcon il
suffisait de mettre quelqu'un à côté du
portrait d' emmanuel macron pour qu'ils
se fassent elior ce serait étonnant que
la fonte des neiges parlementaire de la
république en marche entraîne réellement
un problème par contre ces détails
général du pays qui est inquiétant un
état de tension un état de violences un
président qui n'est même plus à l'abri
de la de par la saf sa dimension
symbolique qui fait qu' il peut être
interpellé
alpagué bousculé et donc la question
importante c'est le ressentiment du pays
le sentiment que les français
certes il a des bus qu'il y avait un
programme emmanuel mâcon n'a pas été élu
sur un programme il a été élu sur sa
personne et un projet le pays ne
regardait pas le programme ce qui le
regarde elle consentait wii étaient
intéressés directement mais c'était la
posture générale qui faisaient le
consentement du pays
hélas le les français s'étaient déjà la
question lors du grand débat est-ce que
les efforts demandés aux français vise à
renforcer le modèle français quitte à
faire des efforts ou est ce un
démantèlement du modèle français et la
difficulté sur le débat sur la réforme
des retraites c'est que au fait plus le
temps passe plus des catégories sociales
inquiètes se met en mouvement contre la
réforme plus treyvaud l'idée qu'en fait
cette réforme ne viserait pas
contrairement
ce qu'annonçait le premier ministre se
référant ses nerfs de solidifier
d'ancrer le modèle mais à le d'éditer et
du coup je pense que il faut observer le
mouvement profond du pays car c'est lui
qu'il fait ensuite la cartographie
électorale pour la présidentielle marine
le pen a annoncé tout de suite qu'elle
était candidate parce qu'elle a besoin
de temps pour continuer à faire muter le
rassemblement national de faire passer
du nationalisme de l'extrême droite a
plutôt une orientation nationale une
posture gaullienne
elle a fait le gros du travail lors des
européennes elle a compris que la france
n'était pas l'angleterre qu'elle ne
pouvait pas contrairement à l'angleterre
se renfermer sur elle au travers de
l'euro et donc le danger pour le
président mâcon c'est le second tour
c'est au fond est ce qu'il de retrouvent
rarement l'ex dont il a bénéficié du
pays de peur de ce qu'un car nous
représente
marine le pen et je pense que c'est ça
qui est dorénavant entachée sssa
dorénavant la difficulté pour lui c'est
qu'il n'a plus du tout aucune garantie
en la matière parce que l a dit marine
le pen a tiré intelligemment les leçons
de son échec à la présidentielle et
surtout il n'ya plus les potez mélenchon
qui lui avait ravi un temps le sceptre
dans les catégories populaires du
patriotisme car mélenchon a mené une
campagne prend fin de campagne
patriotique et jurassiennes et après la
présidentielle
il s'est orienté vers eux je dirais une
ligne plutôt gauchistes voir chez
certains de ses amis islamo-gauchiste
gilles casanova est ce que aujourd'hui
le président de la république pourrait
aurait les solutions pourraient se
mettre à nouveau à l'écouté des français
notamment parlait beaucoup de la réforme
des retraites
on entend beaucoup des demandes de
référendum
aujourd'hui sur la réforme des retraites
on fait un référendum pour savoir si
elle doit passer oui ou non à ce que
c'est quelque chose que le président de
la république pourrait entendre
justement après il y a assez peu de
chance car référendum sur la question
des retraites donne autre chose qu un
non franc et massif au président de la
république
étrange manière de communiquer qu'a eus
le président et le gouvernement
d'expliquer d'abord le président l'a dit
ça n'est pas une affaire d'âge
nous n'aurons pas de réponses par l'âge
puis le premier ministre a dit c'est une
infernale
c'est une réponse par l'âge déjà ça
c'est difficile de suivre cela mais
surtout le grand argument était c'est
une réforme qui rassemble tous les
régimes pour la justice et donc ce sera
mieux pour tout le monde et ensuite on a
annoncé que les catégories les plus
proches de l'exécutif les policiers les
gendarmes allaient en être exemptés à
leur demande
puis successivement les catégories les
plus turbulentes comme les pompiers les
plus indispensables aussi en sont
exemptés les unes après les autres
si elles étaient six excellentes si
bonne si vraiment c'était ce qu'il
fallait aux français pourquoi en
exempter ceux qui sont les plus
indispensables à l'exécutif il est
évident que le message a été entendu
c'est quelque chose qui est une potion
amère et on va en exemple et ce sans
lesquelles on ne peut pas continuer à
faire tourner la machine étatique
ça n'est pas ainsi que l'on acquiert de
la crédibilité donc maintenant il peut
dire ce qu'il veut
il est dans une situation comparable à
celle de nicolas sarkozy dans les
derniers mois il était allé faire un
discours au bureau international du
travail à l'organisation internationale
du travail pardon et ce discours était
remarquable d'intelligence de
d'élévation et mêmes
dans ses propositions aucun chef d'état
occidental n'avait fait quelque chose
d'aussi fouillé d'aussi travail et il
n'a eu aucun écho
alors qu'il aurait pu être applaudie par
le centre gauche
personne n'en a parlé parce que c'est la
parole qui était d'évaluer et bien là il
est dans la même situation
sa parole est dévaluée il va dire
quelque chose et tout le monde s'attend
à ce qu'ils disent autre chose ensuite
stéphane rozès il nous reste une minute
pour conclure est-ce que vous rejoignez
le constate gilles casanova qui dit au
fond emmanuel macron aujourd'hui c'est
terminé plus personne ne l'écoutera je
pense que au fond il n'y aura pas de
solution de communication qui lui
permettront de renouer les choses
pourraient éventuellement y avoir une
politique de moi ou le chaos travers une
dissolution pour renouer avant la
présidentielle mais sans garantie qu'il
n'y ait pas une force néanmoins par
défaut qui arrive à émerger même si pour
l'heure hormis le rassemblement national
on ne voit pas de choses mais c'est un
peu tôt pour le rassemblement national
non comme je pense que le fondement de
notre crise nationale des raisons
essentiellement européenne c'est à dire
qu'il ya une contradiction trop
importante entre une nation qui a besoin
de se projeter et un état qui demande
d'intérioriser au contraire des règles
et des normes dans je dirais conforme à
l'imaginaire allemand
répercuté par bruxelles de bercy je
pense que la crise en allemagne peut
éventuellement donné l'idée au président
qu'au fond on pourrait peut-être faire
comme les autres pays c'est à dire
mettre d'abord notre intérêt national en
avant et que ce serait au fond pas pu
mal pour l'europe qu'elle soit je dirais
la la convergence d'intérêts nationaux
avec des objectifs européens forts et
non pas utiliser bruxelles comme une
justification de politiques dans
lesquelles au fond notre pays pour des
raisons très anciennes ne se reconnaît
pas merci beaucoup
stéphane rozès d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
président de cap enseignant à sciences
po et hec merci avoue gilles casanova je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
stratégie et communication
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
rester avec nous sur rt france dans cinq
minutes un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité à tout
[Musique]
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans les sports que le
terme radicalisation c'est un peu un mot
valise et ont même beaucoup de choses
qui ne reflète pas la réalité lampard de
la radicalisation islamiste dans le
sport c'est tout ce processus qui peut
conduire quelqu'un à se mettre en marge
totale de la société parfois même
basculer vers l'action violente en 2016
- sportif considéré que c'était pas son
affaire et qu'il n'avait pas à être une
sorte de délateurs des pouvoirs plus
parce que le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui
toute une série de phénomènes nous
échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se créent
ou bien des structures qui secret en
dehors du mouvement organisé certains
ont dit le sport amateur c'est le
premier lieu vecteur de radicalisation
c'est faux c'est la prison dans les
clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
mais pas contre les radicaliser ne vont
plus à la mosquée ne sont plus à l'école
ne sont plus dans les clubs retirer vos
de la tête le sport à 6 à lille
[Musique]
je vais au cas où on donne c'est un
conte pour les gens qui ne peuvent pas
être exposé au soleil
ils me disent c'est donc un camp pour
les vampires je crois que c'est que lens
entre l'hébergement pour repère non pas
à parler de tout ce qu'ils traversent
parce que nous comprenons tous notre
chic